et lorsque tu es ce qui est un petit peu
amusant on pas amusant un peu triste et
vous savez qu'elle avait dû annuler
concéder des concerts parce qu'elle
avait dit qu'elle avait des nodules dans
l'avoine elle remontait sur scène à
ottawa il ya quelques jours
et là il ya des vidéos qui circulent
elle a dû mais carrément s'arrêter de
chanter et s'excuser tellement on aurait
dit pardon c'est un peu triste mais
tilton sur la fin de ses concerts
qu'elle avait plus du tout du tout du
tout à chanter et même petite info 2
florian ronsin le petit winnie qui
travaillent avec nous et qui lui dit que
du coup pour les prochaines dates elle
va enlever toutes ses chansons à voix
notamment all by myself et les chansons
il faut monter parce qu'elles n'arrivent
plus à chanter
alors est-ce que du coup ça va passer
est-ce que c'est pas provisoire mais
c'est plus embêtant se pose des
questions on sait déjà pour les les gens
qui sont dans les dents dans l'est la
musique nous disent qu elle a déjà
baissé un petit peu le ton de sa voix
c'est normal les grottes vocale c'est un
muscle à la vieillit elle chante déjà un
peu moins fort qu'avant
qu'est-ce qui se passe regardez ces
terres ottawa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
jégo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour l'été
ça que je vous dis
[Musique]
la moussa keita on a vu que moi qui
connais un peu c'est une dure pas connu
quand on avait fait une émission sur nrj
12 elle était mais très carrée du thé
pas de cigarettes quelqu'un qui aime
fumer à 10 km elle hurlait et la ceiba
qu'on l'a vu ba cigarettes en lui faire
des soirées on l'a vu l'a vu fumer non
non elle est dans un entourage de mode
on l'a vu s'éclater un peu allenby où
elle s'est claqué tout d'un coup quand
elle s'éclate balader preuve sur scène
qu'elle n'avait pas avant et voilà ce
qu'il faut arrêter sa tournée des gens
qu'ils vont payer parfois jusqu'à 500
euros la place pour avoir ensuite
derrière des meet and greet et tout ça
quand on paie ce prix là est ce que
c'est pour voir ça non mais on connaît
moi je suis pour la réorientation de sa
carrière céline dion chante carla bruni
céline dion chanté mon sens qu'elle sort
rebondir de cette manière parce que là
c'est ça fait pas sérieux demandé comme
un furieux enquêtant régis skimming
on me dit est là elle voilà qu'on s'est
raccourcie elle n'a pas chanter ses
tubes avoir all my life
mais est-ce que du coup c'est pour
toutes les dates qui arrive quand même
temps est ce qu'elle va faire ça du coup
ajoutant qu'elle est malade et puis
après elles reprendront elles alors si
pour les cinq prochaines dates donc pas
de bol si vous et votre billet les cinq
prochaines dates elle ne chantera pas
les chansons pas ses tubes pas les
chansons à voix et pour les autres ça
sera blanc et elle c'est triste et de
raccourcis son concert de 20 minutes
c'est incroyable je suis dans le cerveau
de céline dion dans l'oreille mais amère
si céline merci on s'en fiche parce que
c'est tellement un mythe céline dion que
franchement même à les avoir et payer
pour l'avoir été automne aussi mais
crois-moi la zone a été détruite par les
drogues et par l'alcool dans les cas et
perdu sa voix à cause de ses excès la
mort j'ai pas dit ça c'est mignon j'ai
dit que là elle va faire cinq les cinq
prochaines dates elle va raconter le
concert de 20 minutes
elle n'a pas chanter ses tubes pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas annulé red hat on
va quand même l'avoir pour ce genre de
chanson all by myself louis xi a fait
que des chansons douces lyon pour sabrer
les gens qui ont fait pour les gens qui
ont payé les cinq prochains concerts je
comprenne qui est ce qu'on peut en tirer
comme un monta les gros titres et pas
céline ou pas ces lignes tgv quand même
et je
elle est pas entendre ça gros titres tu
peux pas jouer les veuves joyeuses et
assurer sur cet appel parce que
justement c'est lui même quand elle
avait une hygiène de vie irréprochable
ce qu'est que toujours le cas a toujours
été fragile elle a toujours eu des
moments où elle avait aujourd'hui elle
est avec elle donne demande beaucoup à
sa voix avec ses camarades let elle suce
comme tous les athlètes sont souvent
blessé et elle est souvent blessé c'est
vrai et y aller c'est pas sûr que la
tournée n'est pas trop date par rapport
à ses capacités
je n'ai aucun souci avec ça je mettrai
bien qu'elle soit blessée tout ça qu'ils
se protègent jeudi jusque il ya des gens
qui vont payer jusqu'à 500 euros la
place et dans ses crèches étaient ténus
les cinq prochaines dates au sirop de
cassis nous regardent ces gens là bas
c'est pas de bol tout ce que je peux
vous dire